we'll start with the show black mirror
for a second because it is a spectacular
show and people more and more people are
coming to it
yeah it's brilliantly done they don't
make that many yes of this show and it's
kind of like The Twilight Zone
it's sort of a modern version of The
Twilight Zone yeah brought brought to
current times and it's and you really
were attracted to this show in theory
but then you saw it and you were worried
about it yeah when I first watched an
episode of Black Mirror I knew nothing
it was like a year and a half ago like I
hadn't there was no possibility of me
being on black mirror and I was I was
away from my family I was in New Zealand
and and missing them and my husband was
watching black mirror and use like Bryce
you we have to share this like this is
the most phenomenal brilliant you like
it the show is is is like a comment on
what is gonna happen 10 years from now
right and then they and and then they
make it so entertaining and gripping
it's just it's brilliant and it's almost
like a like a foreshadowing for what's
to come
right so he talked you into seeing it so
he talked me into seeing it I was all by
myself and I watched it and it was tough
and I had a nervous breakdown did you
mean I mean you really did have a
breakdown I had I shouldn't say it's
like a clinical nervous breakdown but I
just had a meltdown that show just got
me you know and it was just very
emotional and I sent some videos to my
husband because he was he was asleep in
the United States of America and and I
actually I brought you some of my videos
this is URI real this is actually this
is real this is you not trying to be
you're not amusing reigning you just
this is your reaction to watching black
mirror for the first time first time you
just after you watched it let's take a
look
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you don't matter my mine
you're here to promote this show crazy
so you notice I said I took a nosedive
right so the show that I did a year in a
year later actually I started shooting a
year after I almost to the week of when
I sent my husband this video it's called
nosedive and I didn't make that
connection and I had my first meeting
with the director and I was like oh I'm
so excited he's like so like what was
the first episode of Black Mirror you
watch I was like let me show you my
reaction right and I put on the videos
and then I said I'm I've taken a
nosedive and that's that's what my
character does in this in this show that
I did we have a clip here from your
episode where as you said people are
starting to so yeah and this episode
people are it's kind of like like uber
apps you know how you rate one another
like the uber driver rates you and you
know you rate the uber driver it's a
world in which we all rate one another
so so this is a circumstance in which
and if you get above a certain rating
you have access to certain privileges in
life and if you get below a certain
rating you get denied those privileges
right and I've been executed a long time
ago well this is me going to a
consultant revenue telogen is what it's
called and to try to get my number up I
what stable with this clip from Black
Mirror okay if we drill down into the
numbers you have got a solid popularity
arc here strong overall trajectory let's
just look at the last 24 hours
you see even what's that 8:40 a.m.
you're working hard on your socials
great little uptake there a couple of
minor dings there you cut someone off in
traffic oh just a workplace
okay let's check on your sphere of
influence let me zoom out here
great peripherals strangers like you
that's a plus
healthy inner circle it's good thank you
that's creepy I think that three years
away
you